i
am committed to service
service through my work
service through my life's purpose
and if you make a commitment a conscious
intention to be committed to the work
that you do to the relationships that
you have
your life will unfold with such beauty
and grace through that commitment
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how
billionaires think to get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two desire to learn with
elon musk i was uh
i was always kind of like a crazy kid i
suppose um
i was just very curious about the world
and
um
how do we come to be here
what's the meaning of life and all that
and uh
um
i always had a really intense desire to
understand things and
learn
um
yeah i mean i had sort of an existential
crisis where i guess when i was
11 or 12 or something trying to figure
out what it's all about you know and uh
ultimately
came to the conclusion that um
we don't really know the answer but
uh but if we increase the scope and
scale of civilization then we
uh
we have a much better chance of
understanding the meaning of life and
why we're here or even what are the
right questions to ask so therefore
we should strive to expand the scope and
scale of consciousness
to better understand
the questions to ask about the answer
that is the universe rule number three
recognize mistakes quickly with warren
buffett there are lots of lousy
businesses you know and there's lots of
wonderful businesses
and
my job over the years has been to try
and figure out which is which and i've
made plenty of mistakes i bought a
company called dexter shoes in the early
90s i paid 400 plus million dollars for
it and
it it made a lot of money before i
bought it but you know as soon as i
bought it they pulled some switch or
something and it
immediately started losing money and
and it was because of foreign
competition so on there it was maybe
because i owned it i don't know
and it went to zero
and the worst thing was that i paid for
it in stock so that 400 million in stock
i gave at the time
is uh
now worth about 5 billion so it
so
every time berkshire stock goes down i
feel a little bit better because of my
opportunity
loss on this business but you know when
i looked at dexter's shoe they had a
good position in retailers they turned
out good shoes they had a great
workforce all kinds of things but
i just forgot one thing that that they
weren't going to make shoes in the
united states anymore
so you make you make mistakes and it
does pay
to recognize
quickly when you've made them if you've
got a good person running a business and
it isn't making any money
uh
you know you're in the wrong business
and and you've got to face up to that
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four provide low costs
with jeff bezos directionally
our goal and this has been true for it's
kind of a cultural trait at amazon
our focus is going to be to be the
low-cost provider of these kinds of
high-quality services
so as we are able to get smarter as
we're able to
you know
figure out how to do things more
efficiently we are going to be returning
those cost efficiencies to customers in
the form of lower prices on things like
ec2
um there are other things that you know
that it may be that we need some
instance sizes is instance sizes sizes
that are smaller
than what we have today
uh
so the smallest instance we have today
is 10 cents per compute hour
and we're also looking you know always
at uh you know returning some of the
cost savings we get on things like
bandwidth charges
uh disk space charges and so on and so
on the good news is that those things do
get cheaper over time
and as we get more efficient and
organized we'll be able to return i
think quite a bit of savings to
customers rule number five take risks
with mark cuban i had a fiat x19 that
had a hole in the floorboard i mean you
could tell i was living the high life
right i mean and i was putting in oil
every 60 miles and you know working as a
bartender at night what did i have to
lose right you know and so it wasn't
like oh
man you know this is i could lose all
this um and so
yeah
and so it was just like you just go for
it now later on after i had some success
and we got back and we started audionet
which turned into broadcast.com the the
math was different the equations you
know the calculus was different it was
like okay i'm investing a lot of my
saved money into this whole idea of
net casting right or internet
broadcasting in early 1995 when people
didn't even know what the internet was
that was all risk because i literally
was putting everything that i had on the
line for something people just laughed
at me and said wait
audio
over the internet
you know you can turn on the radio you
know you know you can turn on the tv
yeah but you don't get it no that's just
dumb all right you know and and so being
able to overcome all that resistance
because remember back then a you had to
have a pc
b you had to know what a modem was and
install it c you had to know what the
internet was and then you had to
download a tcp ip client that worked
over a modem and then connected to a
browser that you probably didn't even
know what it was or how to download it
and we had to take it on faith that all
this was going to grow rule number six
build good relationships with tillman
fertitta i
am part of who i am is because of
relationships and and and relationships
in the investment banking world and you
mentioned somebody a few minutes ago
that's friends with both of us uh they
were always there for me now always
performed and if you perform people want
to be there for you i had other
great relationships in the m a world
that worked with me when i was looking
at deals because they knew i was
credible but having great relationships
in the investment banking world that you
developed and i told one of them once i
said you got to make your friends your
friends and and you got to know who to
trust and who have faith in but but
absolutely
i would not be where i am today without
relationships because we knew we could
always count on each other and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is look for
opportunities with grant cardone look if
you're anything like me if you're one of
those people that's like hey i know you
you know inside you you're gonna make it
one day that you're gonna be successful
that you're gonna you're gonna change
the world
look here's the deal you will get your
break okay you just got to keep looking
for it sometimes it's so hard sometimes
it's like why is everybody else making
moves and i can't seem to find my break
keep looking for it all right keep
looking for it 30 years
i wake up every morning and say when am
i gonna get my break okay when am i
gonna get my break i see other people
making moves i'm like why not me
that's happening to you don't get
frustrated don't give up hang in there
be persistent okay post in comments
below what break you're looking for
maybe i can help you i know people
i'd love to help you okay
unfortunately because we have so much
attention on our physical capacity and
limitations five eight
you know i've been a little guy my whole
life got to feed myself three times a
day because i'm hungry i've got to
urinate you know sometimes with my buddy
um i gotta i gotta i gotta sleep
nine hours a day eight to nine hours a
day i'm reminded i'm a body
which has been a deception for me
because that's not what i'm i'm not
limited to just that and so it's been a
big trick
thinking oh i just got to take care of
this i got to clothe it i got to protect
it i got to worry about it the older you
get the more you worry about it kids can
do almost anything
you know kids can jump off a freaking
they can jump out of a car roll around
on the damn grass and pop up and say
yeah that was fun let's do that again
you do that to me man i'm like dang that
hurt right so you can see a kid flying
down a mountain at 70 miles an hour man
i'm i'm terrified because i'm gonna
break something so it's that it's that
concern about me as a like is something
gonna happen to me
if i wouldn't have been concerned about
myself
my god i could have done anything man i
would have already done it
so so that's how i would just that's
been a big limitation
what i was talking about the the
capacity of the individual is
i don't think i've even like remotely
scratched
hopefully if i come back if i can come
back if anybody believes in that kind of
stuff like then i can come back with oh
my god man maybe i'm not just five eight
170 pounds
you know little little tiny little tiny
ones got some good guns right now okay
but maybe i can do more than just a
physical limitations that that i impose
on myself i've created a fund called
cardone capital and it's changing the
way people can invest in real estate so
when i was growing up
and even earl in my early real estate
career i could not buy the best assets
the the best properties
are left for institutions and banks
and and it's super super wealthy i'm not
talking about
i'm talking about the kind of wealth
y'all you're familiar with about and
read about here and i'm not talking
about people that have hundreds of
millions but billions and hundreds of
billions and even trillions of dollars
of available money to them
and so
most people
most even real estate professionals get
the leftovers everything after that
and so i've been playing the real estate
game for 30 years and in the last seven
years figured out okay i'm going to
start buying what jp morgan buys in
blackstone
and i'm going to use my audience on
instagram and facebook
and i'm not going to go get my money
from the institutions i'm going to get
the deal from the institution
and the money is going to come from my
friends and we're going to crowdsource
this money
without paying brokers the brokers never
like to hear me say this
but we've raised 300 million dollars
bought a billion dollars by the real
estate in the last 30 months i paid not
one penny to a broker
wow so that means all that investor
dollars ends up in the investment
saving the investor money and then we
distribute cash distributions every
single month
not every quarter like the banks
distribute every quarter or a reit a
reit will distribute every quarter it's
funny you know people talk about the
power of social media and they they dis
it a lot but
last week
last week kylie jenner 600 million
dollars 51 stake in her business you
have raised 300 million dollars through
crowdfunding because a lot of people are
wasting time on social media they're
getting likes and comments i know
there's a guy flying into town tomorrow
and he's big on free and don't monetize
and and
he he's looking at his likes and
comments and i don't look at likes and
comments i look at hey i have an offer
this is what you could do it's a great
deal for you it's a great deal for me
it's a great deal for everybody that
plays and we want to monetize so i think
i'm going to raise three billion i'm
going to create a 10 billion dollar fund
crowd funding and then the banks are
going to come to me and say we want to
buy that thing handling kind of
criticism and people saying don't do
that or you can't do that because you
know
on any kind of
success journey you do get a lot of that
what how did you kind of handle that
yeah you know in the beginning you're
not ready for i was not ready for the
amount of
um
criticism you know first you're going to
be ignored
in the beginning you're just going to be
ignored nobody's going to even pay
attention to you you could be jesus you
could walk on water and they're going to
ignore you nobody will even see hey did
you see that did you take a selfie did
you get it on instagram if you didn't it
didn't happen so it doesn't matter like
you could literally save the world and
if nobody saw it they're going to ignore
you in the beginning then they're gonna
reject you
third thing they're gonna do is they're
gonna criticize you make fun of you
but if you stay with it they're gonna
adopt it okay i mean brilliant people
are adopted at the end if they just stay
with the hate along the way is part of
the game for you to get past being
ignored and then rejected you will be
hated on
and once you start accumulating enough
success
uh we we were i told my team over here
we got 155 employees i'm like guys look
you have to be ready
it's coming the criticism
the stuff online don't even look at it
it's all garbage
and if it affects you negatively
it's not about what they're saying it's
about what it does to you personally
i just know it's part of the game now in
the beginning i wasn't ready for it now
i understand oh my success is dependent
upon the hate and the criticism and the
rejection
you gotta have it it's part of the it's
part of the recipe of success
unfortunately
because people that quit are going to
hate you for not quitting
they're actually not talking about you
they're talking about themselves
and they're like he's wrong for having a
damn plane
because they quit on their plane
everybody can have a plane
the crazy is everybody can have
everything they want because there's
enough to go around for everybody
so
uh for every guy that doesn't have what
he wants there's somebody on this planet
that has the oceanfront house
that goes on as many trips as they want
some guy that's got the 200-foot yacht
some guy
that funded a hospital somewhere and put
his name on it
and and
you know it's just crazy that
the hate always comes from the same
place
a quitter
haters actually on haters they're
quitters in my industry what are your
best three marketing tips
uh to number one is be everywhere all at
the same time
it's called omnipresence
so omnipresence anything that's the
omnipresence by the way has survived for
since
the the beginning of man 300 000 years
or whatever
whoever can be everywhere will be
assigned power
whether it's the queen or god or
coca-cola
whatever can be everywhere
will be assigned power
and so omnipresence with marketing this
has really never been possible before
until the digital age the last six or
seven years
facebook instagram snapchat youtube
these things that
based on the age of this audience half
of you probably don't use
you know because you're like i don't
have time for that this well-dressed man
right here with the sweater and the
glasses over his nose and this man this
man this very aristocratic
looking gentleman okay he are you on
facebook sir
he's on facebook that's unbelievable
instagram
no youtube
i mean you have a youtube channel i
don't mean you watch my youtube
you have your own youtube channel
okay that's pretty good
so but but but you see like like you
should the answer to your question is be
omnipresent two use all channels all of
them everything i'm gonna use youtube
snapchat
linkedin twitter
i'm gonna use
newspapers
even though most people aren't reading
newspapers i'm going to use magazines
i'm going to use
that's that's marketing i'm going to use
expo events like this events like
stages like this i'm going to use
telephone calls cold calling warm
calling
i'm going to use billboards if you go to
miami right now you'll see 28 massive
billboards throughout
miami a million dollars worth of
marketing material where i'm introducing
where i live
the business owners to my name
so i would use every uh
marketing means possible
lastly the number three thing is i would
have
your marketing budget
be
have a target of your last year's income
i i would spend more money on marketing
than i do people and i would spend more
money on people than than i could even
imagine i would just spend more money
you know there was this book written
called uh the millionaire next door it
was a big sensation too a lot of people
read this book it was a super super hit
big hit book okay and when i read the
book i was like
i got something different from it than
what other people got from it other
people were like okay i'm not i'm not
going to coffee shops anymore okay i'm
not going to buy a brand new car anymore
what i got was i don't want to be the
millionaire next door
that's what i got from the book so it's
all about your viewpoint right when when
i finished reading the book i was like
okay i don't want to be a millionaire
and i'm definitely not going to take
advice from a millionaire because when
you get a million dollars if you if you
came from if you came up the way you and
i did and you had nothing i give you a
million dollars and you're going to
think dude
oh my god i've got a million dollars
your mom's going to kiss you oh god i
always knew you could make it right
uh
and then and then and then you're gonna
wake up the next morning and say dude i
don't want to lose this money
you go into conservation into defense
you start playing defense
i was with mike tyson i did mike tyson's
podcast the boxer right well in 19 years
old mike was a champion of the world
yeah
when mike got in the ring man
in in when he was at his
perfection
he didn't hit you once he hit you and he
kept hitting you until you went down
there was
attack attack attack attack attack
attack attacking two you couldn't get up
two you're like you're just gonna even
if the body can get up you're like i
don't want to get up now because i can't
win this
and that is the way people should be
attacking life right
when mike started getting data i even
told him this i said dude when you went
to the therapist when you started
therapy is when you started having
problems
gwen you're right grant
grand you're right when you stop seeing
the therapist you got better because the
therapist puts you on defense what are
you doing
you start going on defense you start
looking at where you made your mistakes
as opposed to saying hey dude what
worked let's repeat it
let's don't do destructive stuff yeah
let's get rid of whatever is driving the
destructive behavior right but
with money man with money what you want
to do is you want to double down
this is why the casinos never never you
know get broke because nobody bets
enough in the casinos if all the whales
showed up
in macau
or in in right here in london or or in
vegas and all the whales showed up at
one weekend and said hey we're going to
break the bank and we're gonna all push
in hard they could take down the casino
but because all the little guys go to
the bank they they lose five they lose
five they lose five they win 15. they
say i'm out of here yeah okay if they
break even they think they had a big
night when trying different things
you got to have some acceptance of
failure as you were alluding to earlier
failure must be an option if failure is
not an option it's going to result in
extremely conservative choices and
you may not may get something even worse
than lack of innovation things may go
backwards
so
if
what you really want is
[Applause]
risk risk to you you want reward and
punishment
to be proportionate to the actions that
you seek
so if
uh if what you're seeking is innovation
then you should reward success and
innovation
um and
only
there should be
minor consequences for lack of
minor consequences for for trying and
failing
should there should be minor
with significant rewards for trying and
succeeding
minor consequences for trying and not
succeeding
um and big
and
major negative consequences for not
trying or maybe i just blank out the
word doubt
um
so uh no i mean i totally frank i
doubted us too so i thought we you know
had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right you know um i mean there were
times
that i was told like
uh because i was taking the money that i
earned from from paypal and enrolling
into
to create spacex and tesla and and i
ended up spending it all it wasn't the
intention but
um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon one
um
and uh
so but a lot of times i was you know i
people would tell me this joke like how
do you make a small fortune in the
rocket industry you start with a large
one is the punchline
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you
know so
so um
anyway um and it was it almost came true
um
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to save the company we also then had to
win the nasa cargo resupply contract um
so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later all right
towards the end of 2008
those are the two key things that that
saved spacex otherwise we would have we
would have you know
not made it so
um
so hey i think those those doubters were
their probability assessment was correct
um but unfortunately uh vader smiled
upon us and brought us to this day as
you look back on your career in the
space industry what has been the most
surprising or unexpected challenge that
you faced and along those lines if you
were to go back in time and talk to your
20 year old self would you do anything
differently
go back in time
to your 20 year old self
i mean i think i'd if i could i think it
would make up my far fewer mistakes
obviously if i could go
like here's a list of all the dumb
things you're about to do please do not
do them
yeah wouldn't we all be a very long list
and like
here let me
write it down or something you know
um
i mean it's hindsight's 2020. so it's
hard to say
um
i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i have a lot count
honestly
i mean some of these things i just wish
i'd like that like that's
simple sort of mantra
management by rhyming i mean it worked
for homer okay
um
the management by rhyming is
the thing i'm saying like if but if the
schedule is long the design is wrong
we've overcomplicated the design many
times
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design
um
with the acid test being
how long will it take to
for this to fly
and if it's gonna take a long time don't
do it do something else i think we we
need to push for radical breakthroughs
um
and if you don't push for radical
breakthroughs you're not going to get
radical outcomes
um
and that that does mean taking risks
um
and yeah
common sense that
the if you take a big risk in order to
have a big reward there must be a big
risk it's most the time you cannot find
a big reward for small risk that's why
those are rare
um so you're going to have some
proportionality of the risk and reward
you've got to differentiate yourself i
always ask myself why am i different how
am i different and i think it's very
important to be
i call them the three c's but clear
concise and confident you have to be
able to describe it in a minute or less
make it so clear the customer really
wants to make smart decisions and they
really want us to make it easy for them
so i always say make somebody feel the
pain or if it's not the pain
which means the problem on why you did
what you did or why you're creating what
you create then explain to them your
uniqueness and then right after that
you've got to give them the solution
very quickly and then take it through
and say why you're the best i mean very
quickly
explain to them in just a few seconds
why you're the best option
and i find that very very helpful so in
everything i do i ask myself why am i
different i would call myself a girl who
really likes to challenge herself to do
things that scare her to auditioning at
disney world
i ended up at disney world because i
failed the lsat and i felt very
sad that i most likely wasn't going to
be heading off to law school i am a
terrible test taker so i did what my
parents said of course would be the most
natural thing to do and i got in my car
and drove to disney world and tried out
to be goofy
and just to add you know
insult to injury i'm too short to be
goofy so i just failed the lsat i went
through all the auditions to become a
character and you have to be five eight
to be goofy and i'm five six so i'm the
height of a chipmunk oh really yes
so they wanted to make me a chipmunk
first of all my goal is not disruption
for the sake of instruction um i i
really
think there's okay there's some
important things we have to solve in
order for the future to be good yeah i
would say like my you know
my sort of algorithm or optimization is
like okay what set of things do we need
to do
uh to ensure that the increase the
probability of the future is going to be
good yeah and so if we if we have to
solve sustainable energy yeah this is
total logical if we do not solve
sustainable energy then we have
unsustainable energy then it's just a
matter of time before things go before
civilization collapses we must but even
beside even if there was not an
environmental issue uh since the
availability of oil is limited yeah uh
this is not something we can sustain
long term yeah my original interest in
electric vehicles was actually not
environmental it was out of concern just
you know studying physics and i'm like
wait a second yeah we we immediately
transitioned to uh solar electric yeah
uh or we're gonna have a problem and and
we run out of oil civilization collapses
that's a problem now of course the
environmental concerns uh have
added to the uh urgency
because the the more uh co2 co2 we put
in the oceans and atmosphere the more we
increase the probability that uh
something will go wrong
um like i said like things are much more
probability as opposed to certainty uh
but i think it's an unwise experiment to
dramatically increase the co2 yeah in
the atmosphere and oceans yeah it's just
given that we know we need to transition
anyway because we ran out of oil yeah so
why run that experiment it's not it
doesn't make any sense um we know we
have to transition to a sustainable
energy economy
um then let's just get on with it yeah
you know let's just get on with it and
not run the crazy experiment and see if
the what happens if the atmosphere has
2000 ppm
co2 this is crazy look for
evidence of exceptional ability
so it's not
at least aspirationally like sometimes
these things get
messed up in
recruiting or the recruiting fault of
things ends up being wrong like i
sometimes wonder with tesla
if nikola tesla applied to tesla would
we even give him an interview
it's not clear
you know this guy came from like some
weird college and
somewhere in eastern europe i think he's
got some odd mannerisms now we don't
know if we should give an interview like
i i worry that that's actually what we
do instead of like
right it should be like man [ __ ] this
this this kid's super smart
what does he want we'll pay him anything
that should be that that should be the
reaction if nikola tesla applies you
know to tesla um ironically
but so but i can tell you the intent is
we're looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh and it really
doesn't matter if you want to graduate
high school or college or anything we're
just looking for evidence of exceptional
ability
such that it would be a good predictor
for doing exceptional things spacex
really considered cost actually just
means that if there are
you want to look at both the benefits
and the cut the cost actually so if uh
if in um sequestering carbon removing it
from the uh atmosphere or oceans uh
uh it has has some uh
perhaps some environmental
impact uh
which might be small but it's not
negative that certainly needs to be
taken into account um
and uh
uh and then a bystan token if uh what's
done is
in extracting carbon is a useful product
sure that from which you can generate
revenue then that should count too all
right so and i'm just sort of saying for
argument's sake like let's say
uh you could create um
you know
construction material like you know um
come with cement cement yeah which we
just i'll talk about that later some
kind of
useful rocks that are rocks that are
useful or sand or i don't know yeah um
something that's useful for construction
um
then uh you could say okay well this is
what we could sell it for and uh
you know and then
just fully consider pros and cons and
and and say okay this is what
you know if um
if we need to pay to have it done in the
future which we probably will have to do
then
um
what's the what's the lowest net cost
ted williams wrote a book called the
science of hitting and ended he had a
picture of himself at bat and the strike
zone broken into i think 77 squares
and he said if he waited for the pitch
that was really in his sweet spot he
would bat 400 and if he had to swing at
something on the lower corner he would
probably bat 235
and in investing i'm in a no called
strike business which is the best
business you can be in
i can look at a thousand different
companies and i don't have to be right
on every one of them or even 50 of them
so i can pick the ball i want to hit
and the trick in investing
is just to sit there and watch pitch
after pitch go by and wait for the one
right in your sweet spot and if people
are yelling swing you bum ignore them
there's a temptation
for people to act
far too frequently in stock simply
because they're so liquid
over the years you develop a lot of
filters and i do know what i call my
circle of confidence so i i stay within
that circle
and i don't worry about things that are
outside that circle
defining what your game is where you're
going to have an edge is enormously
important the allowance when i was a
little boy was a nickel a week but i
like the idea of
having a little more than a nickel a
week to work with and i went into
business very early
i started selling coca-cola door-to-door
i sold gum door-to-door or sold saturday
in post liberty magazine ladies home
journal you name it
[Music]
i think i enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
but i like being my own boss
that's one thing i like about delivering
papers
i could arrange the route i wanted
nobody was bothering me at five or six
in the morning
[Music]
i was delivering 500 papers a day and i
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding
that penny shirt into something else i
was filling up my calendar with so much
non-essential stuff yes non-productive
things because i felt obligated to say
yes to lunch meetings you meet this guy
for 15 minutes where you take this call
and i just don't want to be like oh
jesse is an [ __ ] he won't take this
meeting or so i would just do it and i
realized like i was losing control of my
own time
and like i lost control of my own time
so i just said i started saying no to
everything canceling everything that
that wasn't going to really that i
didn't need to do right that was other
people putting demands on me and i
really started focusing on me i mean i
think so much of business is a
reflection of you
and so many of us don't
don't invest in ourselves yes so i drew
a little pie chart of my time of how i
want to spend my time
and in my 24 hours i broke it up into
four different sections and i make sure
that every day i have three hours for me
so i can you know because i think it's
just so important that we put ourselves
first
and we really don't so many of us don't
you get all these arrows shot at you
every day bills
problems friends need this work the
plumber has to come because this is
broken this thing won't start it's like
you're always dodging arrows right
there's no way around that but if you
don't take the three hours to at least
separate separate yourself from the
constant attack of arrows you're crazy
you'll see something be curious be
interested and do more than just the you
know the casual hey it's nice to meet
you it is i mean if i if i find someone
that's inspiring or an event or
something i try to introduce he she or
it to my life and that's part of just my
own personal development you know i
learn better through experience than
through books
i like to be challenged and i love
interesting people i like people that
are think differently that act
differently that's what attracts me
that's just what makes me feel like i'm
getting the most out of life you know
and that is
i'm on the constant search for that
because i'm very aware of my own
mortality you know i'm 50 years old i'm
turning 50 and the average american
lives to be 78
and if that were the case and i was
average that means i got 28 years left
and that dictates well who do i want to
spend that time with and what do i want
to do
and that's a driving you know it's like
on repeat in my head
so to answer your question you know
that's that's sort of what makes me tick
i always
was dancing to my own drum my parents
gave me a really long leash which is a
great gift for me growing up they let me
do whatever i wanted to do
within reason yeah and i always you know
all of us we always come against this
wall of fear you know this crazy wall of
fear and you can either go to the wall
and turn around you can go through the
wall yes and i was i always every time i
went around turned around and went back
home because i was too scared i had
crazy resentment
or crazy guilt that i wasn't able to do
it regret not resentment yeah regret
yeah and every time i went through the
wall and got to the other side it was so
addicting and i was so proud of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up i grew up
in new york city uh on long island in
the 80s when break dancing and rap and
all this stuff was happening yep and i
was really into breakdancing i don't
know i don't look like it and but you
know get some cardboard out here man we
need to do something might get some
cardboard okay
and um i decided that like i could make
more money probably if i went to
washington dc you know because the kids
in washington dc couldn't be as good as
the kids in new york we invented this
whole genre so i got my friend myron
who's my partner my sister just got her
driver's license and i convinced her to
drive us to washington dc and the whole
drive down i was having all that
self-doubt yeah you know at a young age
14 15 years old like what if the kids
are better what if no one shows up what
if we get booed what if you know what if
we go there and i stink
and so i was almost talking myself out i
was building the wall of doubt up brick
by brick in my own head yeah and when we
got there we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot of a bank and we hit play
and my friend started spinning on his
head and he passed it to me and the
crowd gathered around and ultimately
after i did my thing more people came i
took my hat and i passed it around and
we made about 200 i paid my sister for
the gas money and then myron and i split
82. 41 each and this guy you know he's
counting up the money and he's counting
up the money and he gets all the money
and then he sprints over to me and he
gives me a bear hug and he goes jess
we're
rich
[Laughter]
and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip despite
all the fear this young little kid that
was so scared
i went around that wall
and i realized i could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that if
you had to define the american dream
what would you say it is that when you
think
that there's all the opportunity you
want
and you don't know any better you go
after it
in my generation it was a pleasure work
whether it was at the variety boys club
at seven years old making flower pots
going on selling them or christmas cards
at nine or uh going on the streets at
allah at 11 years old delivering morning
newspapers
for us it was fun to work now what do we
do with the money we gave to my mom so
we have a better way of life we've
gotten to high school my brother and i
saved a little bit of it for our car
which happened to be a junker but we
rebuilt it in auto shop but because we
for us it was a pleasure to work you
know just because wow we got a job it
was so cool many times i've gone with
what i thought was fact and sometimes
which i thought were pretty good hunches
and i didn't do so well but i'm very
fortunate that more than 50 percent of
the time i did do very very well and i'm
finding out more recently in my life the
last couple years that you try not to
just think with your brain but think
with your heart how do you feel about
the situation how do you feel about the
people no matter how kind they are and
i've had some really nice people uh got
in foreign countries and everything else
that were the nicest people in the world
turned out to be total rip-offs but i
didn't know that i there were clues
along the way so i say to everybody and
i say to myself now
feel the person out or feel the
situation with your heart what is your
instinct i think now more in life
that i go off instinct plus facts
obviously you have to have some facts
along with it does it become easier the
more you do it yep much easier when
you're when you're set to well how do i
feel about this shall we say with data
stable data that i have how do i feel
about these facts and then and how i
feel about it just my intuition how do i
feel about it from my heart and the more
you think about doing it that way the
more it happens when you're down and out
first thing people do is blame it on
everybody else but themselves
when you start taking responsibility you
have a little different outlook you also
have the responsibility of turning
things around when i started paul
mitchell i was homeless once again
totally by accident
and i started the company out of the
back seat of my car how old were you at
that time 37 that was 34 35 at that time
so you're homeless at 34 35 again and
what was this series of events that led
to that second time it was just that we
had money set up a half a million bucks
we needed to start the company with that
kind of money and uh the day i was ready
to start go down the bank and get the
money my partner the hairdresser paul
mitchell flew her from hawaii with his
girlfriend and uh we were ready to get
the money and get going get started i'd
left everything i did my relationship
wasn't working out so left the house
plenty of money for many months with her
had a few hundred bucks in my pocket
took the used car which is 20 years old
but a decent one okay down the hill to
get the money wow i was going to check
into an efficiency and all set up the
money never came in no way nev the guy
changed his mind 1980 81 inflation in
the united states is 12 and a half
percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate
17
wow we stayed in line to get gasoline
and interest uh and unemployment was ten
and a half percent the united states the
guy said yours hostages are still in
iran which they were at that time he
says is this a terrible i'm sorry it's
the last minute no
so as a matter of
what are we going to do
what is your decision-making process or
thinking when it comes to investing your
time your money your energy sure uh it's
very important because time is the most
valuable thing you have is one make sure
where you're putting your time and
energy
is something you want to do
not just because you're exploring with
people you don't like or a business you
don't like or a situation you don't like
time is so valuable try and speak if
you're speaking to people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you can do something with to do
something great not just make money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone just to make
money then it means you've already
decided to take a portion of your time
to make these papers that are backed up
by nothing but will buy stuff
call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great possessions
could you give them away
if you had any possession you could give
it away
i think that
um all if you're his founder or
entrepreneur what you want to aim for is
monopoly you want to aim to build a
company that is one of a kind and that
it's so far um differentiated from the
competition that it's not even competing
um
and and i think this is the conventional
wisdom is always that capitalism and
competition are somehow synonyms i
believe they're antonyms a capitalist is
someone who's in the business of
accumulating capital a world of perfect
competition is a world where all the
profits are competed away if you want to
compete like crazy um then you should
just open a restaurant in chicago
and um
and and i think the the great companies
like google sort of the paradigm example
i use has had no serious competition in
search since 2002 when it definitively
distanced itself from yahoo and
microsoft and as a result it's been
generating enormous cash flows for the
last 12 years
assembling a crew of people who are very
smart
very fast learners was kind of the key
to a success in a startup as opposed to
trying to get someone who had you know
if they had 10 years experience doing
something that's great but the more
fundamental characteristic is would they
learn fast on the new problems and the
new challenges yeah it's it always feels
wrong to be anti-experienced but the uh
the place where it can backfires if the
experience makes you think that you know
everything yes and so it's again
uh it's important to know things and
it's important to be open to learning
more and in theory experience is a plus
in practice it's often uh often a bit of
a minus because people are less open to
learning new things or they're more set
on doing a particular job in the context
of startup which is always very tricky
where you have small numbers of people
and people need to be very flexible
about the roles and the roles change as
the company gets built i was paying my
way through school and i was working as
a waitress at denny's and
it was a challenging denny's and so what
i mean by that is um they had problems
getting pancakes out and people get so
frustrated so it would take an hour
sometimes to get your meal so i would
talk and try to like you know learn the
customer stories yeah i would you know
anything you didn't have to ring up like
the ice cream i would i would offer ice
cream whatever anyways i got fired for
talking too much
yeah yeah from denny's but it was a
blessing to go through right because i
learned a lot too and i was like okay
trying to understand i didn't know at
the time i'd be an entrepreneur later
trying to also make sure i figured out
operations so even when you're sitting
there inside of a kitchen going why is
it taking 45 minutes to get pancakes and
what's the ordering process and the back
end of the operations it's all a gift
like everything we go through can be
that way um
and if we have the mindset where we go
okay what can i learn from this
experience and what can i take out of it
and and learn from it wherever you're at
in life right now at this very moment
i believe everyone has a knowing inside
of them i don't think it matters if they
have a faith or no faith i don't think
about any of that i think everyone
universally has a knowing or a truth
inside
and i think most people never learn how
to get still and hear it and most people
if they do get still and hear it they're
going to know right now live while
they're listening to you and me
are they in the right
job they're supposed to be in
or
is there is are they are they playing it
small
are they in the right relationship
or are they in it and dimming their own
light because of fear that maybe they'll
be alone we all have a knowing right and
you know what i'll say about the idea of
giving up leveling up all of that
i think it's so important that
um you know in that moment where i had
the and again let me just say there's so
much i did wrong and i share all that
stuff too one of the things i did right
was when i had this this gut feeling as
i'm sitting there with this skin problem
this gut feeling oh you're supposed to
figure out how to how to create a beauty
company even though i knew nobody in the
beauty industry had no connections had
very little money because television
news does not pay very well um
i had that knowing right and yet i was
sitting there in my dream job and
when i look back at this journey of
three years of constant rejection down
to under a thousand dollars in a bank
account
literally getting knocked down over and
over from all of these beauty retailers
that i put on a pedestal and i couldn't
understand why they were telling me i
wasn't the right fit for them
every time i would check in with my gut
right and maybe so many people out there
can relate to this because you you feel
like you're doing something you're
supposed to be doing but like for me
there was no proof around me that my
idea was right there was no traction in
my business there was nobody saying yeah
that's a great idea let me buy your
product and then i'm going to the beauty
retailers and they didn't believe in the
brand and everything around me was
saying you're wrong
and
the easiest thing in life is to confuse
that
with the truth
and i think the only way we know the
truth in life is when we get good at
getting still and hearing that inner
knowing yeah what was called beautiful
i didn't see myself in right and so i
had this whole idea which is part of why
all the retailers were saying no in the
early years i had this idea to not just
create products that work but let me
show
models all different people every age
skin tone skin challenge gender identity
skin problem size like let me just show
real people and prove this product works
like let me go on qvc and prove it live
let me show my own rosation i just
thought if people can see people look
like them this just makes sense to me
but all the experts said it didn't so
so back to me standing there with this
investor saying i don't think people
will buy makeup from someone who looks
like you with your body and your weight
after i went in my car and cried
like it's rejection always still hurts
uh i also just remember feeling like wow
he's passing on investing in my business
on he's making a business decision
because
of exactly why i'm starting this company
like he's just as much
i don't want to call it a victim but
just as much impacted by
by the definition of beauty that's out
there
and he's literally passing on investing
in my company because of it and so it
drove my deep why for like why i was
building this company
and i took that rejection as fuel for
like oh this has got to change right and
for me it was like let me build a
company
where we show all types of beauty where
where it wasn't even just about selling
product it wasn't about solving my own
problems and even though i want to help
millions of women and all that
the real why was like can i shift
culture and beauty
um for every little girl out there
who's about to start doubting yourself
and every grown person who still does
and so like that drive
fueled it and
not being afraid of rejection is so huge
and it's it's really huge for women
because it prevents a lot of people from
even trying
and it hurts it always sucks
it's priceless to be able to do that uh
life is short life should be fun and it
should be fun not you know it should be
if if the the chairman of the company is
having fun you know if you go to a party
and
you know if i let my hair down and i'm
the first to be thrown in the swimming
pool and uh and i'm not just sitting
standing in the corner of the room
sipping sherry or something then
everybody will have a laugh and
everybody have it fun you know if your
gemini company be the first to dance on
the table you know just get everybody
else up dancing on the table and make
sure the parties you know the parties
are laughed so uh you know so play hard
and uh play hard work hard and
and you know follow certain principles
in life you know be you know
you know love people make make sure you
make a positive difference in this world
while you're on it looks like um you
always go out of your comfort zone right
coming onto an island that was
completely deserted no fresh water you
don't even have the money to buy it and
um and now you're sleeping on a tent on
the beach trying to figure out how to
get fresh water here you do that often
you did it with the airline i mean i was
just somebody that experienced the bad
experience of traveling on airlines
i was actually
trying to get to the bvi the british
virgin islands one day from puerto rico
and the same lovely lady was waiting for
me and i'd been away for three weeks and
american airlines bumped the flight and
and i went to the back of the airport i
hired a plane um
i hired a blackboard
uh i wrote um virgin airlines uh one way
29 to the bvi went around all the people
had been bumped and i filled my first
plane and and that got me thinking you
know that airlines do bump people they
don't care about you or me particularly
in the air and so we
um so i then rang up boeing and said you
have any second hand seven four seven
okay i mean it was literally that you
just sat in the airport and said i'm
starting an airline right now because
i'm frustrated exactly and i think most
most of the best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration i think you know if you're
if you're
frustrated about something
the best way of sorting it out is get
out and do it and you've got yourself a
business you know the 99 95 5 rule there
are no spare you know 95 of everything
we do is right every day in business but
look for the 5 you do wrong and that's
what makes you better than everybody
else there are no spare customers okay
it's a competitive world and every one
of our businesses take no out of your
damn vocabulary you you're on a business
trip and it's 1102 you hang up the phone
and and on a call and you call down to
order some breakfast and they say i'm
sorry sir we don't serve breakfast
anymore that's okay no problem i don't
need a waffle or or an eggs benedict
just throw a couple eggs and a skillet
and send them up scrambled however it's
easy for you to do i'm sorry sir we
don't serve breakfast why are you
telling me no i didn't ask you for
anything special you're gonna throw a
burger in the pan just throw me a couple
of eggs and take care of me be you're in
the hospitality business okay and you're
telling me no and everybody's in the
hospitality business no matter what they
do you take care of your customer okay
you take care of your customers it's no
different than we walk in and your
people meet us polite you put a welcome
up on the screen you come in here
everybody couldn't be can i get you some
water tell me can can i do this for you
you're in the service business so why do
you want to be an ass and and say no to
somebody when it's just as easy to say
yes or do you just give an alternative
the company's being run by somebody
who's not you mentioned people are
looking at the wrong things they're
thinking about the price or the other
things what should they be thinking
about if they want to acquire something
whether you're a small business owner
that wants to acquire something for 100
grand
or you're you know a billionaire like
yourself trying to require something for
2.2 billion what is the thing they look
for well if it's something that you
really really want and you can afford
and it doesn't really matter
uh you should just go get it okay if
it's why is that for the peace of mind
just for the peace of mind and so you
never regret it okay i uh i can go back
20 25 years ago and i've been asked this
the last few days what is
i had a chance to buy this unbelievable
car collection about 25 years ago that
had great muscle cars right when they
were it was unbelievable and i was
really buying it at a bargain because
the father had died the sun was selling
it didn't give a damn
and and and
i lost a deal over a couple hundred
thousand dollars that today if i own
that i would just walk in there and say
this is mine i just love it and and i've
and i learned a lesson and and 25 years
later that's the one deal that comes
back and haunts me because i negotiated
a little bit too hard for something that
really mattered now
now let's look at in a box of a real
business deal you can't get caught up
emotionally there's always another deal
and i walk away from deals all the time
really all the time because there's
there's always another deal but you know
what there's only so many great car
collections so there's only one nba team
in your own hometown okay and so there's
certain things you don't worry about and
that's where you have to be smart and
say there's always another
casino to buy or another restaurant
company to buy but but but keep keep it
right know what's in the box and know
it's out of the box tell people your
your concept of the paddle well there's
a paddle for everybody's ass we all know
that and uh every day you just get up
and i don't fear anything but i worry
about everything and the day you stop
worrying in good times the paddle will
get you behind and and and so as great
as things are in life i know you're only
a few steps or a few incidents away
from something bad happening you can
never forget it did you have fear as a
kid and you just got into enough
business scuffles that you figured your
way through things or have you always
been fearless i'm pretty fearless but i
do worry about everything but
you know once again you know the book
and this is why harper's asked me to
write the book because of all my tillman
isms you got to know what you know and
what you don't know
and and i knew that i understood
business now don't ask me to you know go
win an emmy i took guitar lessons for
four years and i still struggle playing
a guitar i can't draw a stick person
very good but i knew that i understood
business so i i know what i know and i
know how to do due diligence on a deal i
don't worry about making a bad deal
because i feel like
that's what i know
so
no fear when it comes to that i have to
say
i never had that big you know
hit over the head with where i had to
you know sell a car or sell a house or
whatever because things weren't going
well and yet i've been through some
tough times
but but but also and i i talk about this
in the book
don't ever outlive
where you are in in in your business
life and you know what that means is is
that there's so many people that get a
little success in a business
and they go get a lifestyle
that is bigger than the business and
then all of a sudden the business takes
a dip a little bit
and and and they've got to keep up this
lifestyle so they're sucking more money
out of the business than they should
you know i complain to my people all the
time i'm poor i don't have any money
because because i always put everything
back in the business and i just try to
take out a few crumbs to live on because
i've always made the business first and
not me first but that's why i have a
great business and i own 100 of it so it
really doesn't matter but a lot of
people
start they start with a company and and
they become entrepreneurs they get some
success and they're buying more houses
they can afford or more cars or art or
they look philanthropy though i want to
be recognized for giving this away and
then all of a sudden their business dips
and they can't do it anymore and then
their business fails because they took
all the money out and they're not
putting it back in because they're
trying to keep their lifestyle i always
made my business number one i never put
myself
ahead of my business and that's one of
the reasons i've gone like this the
funny thing is with enough persistence
most things that seem impossible
become possible
uh
i'm always amazed at how often you can
turn things around
and people take no for an answer too
easily
you know it's whether you're trying to
achieve a goal like get into business
school
or
my green card was the same way i left
the job
that had sponsored me but i still got my
green card even though no lawyer would
take me i became my own lawyer
got my green card without working for
while i was at business school
and i did it perfectly legally i my
strategy there was if i couldn't
convince immigration i'd confuse them
and i did
and they gave me my green card
most of the time when you start
something you want to do something
meaningful
and get started
and maybe smaller
but you want to keep innovating building
on it one step at a time
and hopefully it becomes much larger
you know
amazon started with just books now it's
everything
if you look at twitter or facebook when
they started they were relatively small
things
mokshaka was trying to connect
everybody on the harvard campus
not seven billion people on the planet
but he kept expanding his vision so very
often when you start with an innovative
idea you don't know how big it is in
fact most of most of the really
innovative ideas have been very hard to
predict what's a large opportunity or a
small opportunity
most people thought
airbnb would this be this very small
nichey little opportunity that a few
people would rent out their rooms and
it'd be a nice little business
now it's huge
people thought uber would be this limo
service business it's now bigger than
all limos all taxis and maybe replacing
personal transportation
so it's not possible to always predict
everything and where things may go
but just because you can't predict where
things may go
doesn't mean
you shouldn't try
or you shouldn't start once you start
and you stay creative and innovative and
keep trying new things
things expand
add some value
there's a true
societal and business value proposition
there's a contribution
i find
and i don't do this for
reasons other than the fact that you
can't
long term
build a viable business without making a
real contribution
most people
look at
they can start a business do an ipo make
some money
almost always that leads to
businesses that are round trips what i
call good they go up and go down
to build a durable business you really
have to focus on the value proposition
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more advice from billionaires
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i know i want to
watch that little guy grow up um and so
it's i don't want to be 80 and think
shoot you know i miss that whole thing
and i don't have the kind of
relationship with my son that i wished i
had and so